nos dicen que queremos encontrar los
ceros de este polinomio y nos dan el
polinomio que tenemos aquí y está en
forma factor izada y dice en trazar
todos los ceros las intersecciones en x
del polinomio en el gráfico interactivo
y esta es una captura de pantalla de
canacar de mí si lo estás haciendo en
khan academy puedes hacer clic donde
están los ceros para dibujarlos pero
sólo voy a marcarlos así que pausa este
vídeo y trata de resolverlo antes de
trabajar juntos en esto muy bien ahora
trabajemos juntos de modo que los ceros
son los valores de x que hacen que
nuestro polinomio sea igual a 0 así que
otra forma de pensar lo es para cuáles
valores de xp de x es igual a 0 esos
serían los ceros esencialmente tenemos
que decir que valores de x harían que 2x
x 2 x más 3 x x menos 2 porque esto es p
de x que valores de x hacen que esto sea
igual a 0 bueno como hemos hablado en
vídeos anteriores si tomas el producto
de estas cosas y eso es igual a cero
si alguna de estas cosas es igual a 0 al
menos una de estas cosas es igual a 0
hacen que todo el producto sea igual a 0
así que por ejemplo si 2x es igual a 0
harían que todo fuera igual a 0 entonces
2x podría ser igual a 0 y si 2x es igual
a 0 eso significa que x es igual a 0 y
puedes intentarlo si x es igual a 0 esta
parte de aquí va a ser igual a 0 no
importa cuáles sean estas otras dos
cosas cero por algo por algo va a ser
igual a cero y luego se podría decir
bueno tal vez 2 x 3 es igual a 0 así que
podríamos simplemente escribir eso 2 x 3
es igual a 0 y si eso fuera cierto
cuanto tendría que valer x para que esto
fuera cierto resta 3 de ambos lados 2x
tendría que ser igual a menos 3 o equis
sería igual a menos 3 medios así que
este es otro valor de x quería que todo
fuera 0 porque si x es igual a menos 3
medios entonces 2x más 3 es igual a 0
tomas un cero por cualquiera que esto
sea y sea lo que sea esto obtendrás cero
y luego por último pero no menos
importante x2 podría ser igual a cero
eso haría que todo el producto fuera
igual a cero entonces qué valor de x
hace que x menos 12 igual a 0 sumamos 2
a ambos lados y obtenemos que x es igual
a 2 si x es igual a 2 esto es igual a 0
no importa que sean estas otras dos
cosas cero por algo por algo va a ser
igual a cero así que tenemos los ceros
de nuestro polinomio y la razón por la
que dice intersecciones en x entre
paréntesis aquí es que ahí es donde está
la gráfica de px si dices es igual a p
de x
ahí es donde cruza el eje x y eso es
porque es ahí donde nuestro polinomio es
igual a cero así que veamos tenemos x
igual a 0 que está justo aquí una vez
más si estás haciendo esto en khan
academy simplemente haz clic justo aquí
y pondrá un pequeño punto tenemos x
igual a menos 3 medios
que es lo mismo que menos uno y un medio
así que eso está justo aquí y luego
tenemos x es igual a 2 que está justo
aquí así que estas son las
intersecciones en x o los ceros de este
polinomio ahora eso es útil en la vida
porque podrías usarlo para graficar una
función no sea exactamente como se ve
esta función tal vez se ve como algo así
o tal vez se ve algo como esto
tendríamos que probar algunos otros
valores para tener una idea de cómo se
ve pero al menos sabemos que los ceros
están donde se intersecta el eje x